we were taking phone calls today six one
seven eight three zero four seven five
zero is the number we don't screen for
topic we don't screen all we want to
know is the name of the person calling
the town they're calling from let's
start there hello you're on yeah I'm
just wondering here your tops on there
catalyst my thoughts on capitalism just
generally speaking yeah is it a good
thing for society well listen I I am
what i would call a regulated capitalism
advocate i like the idea of being able
to have a business of being able to say
hey you know what there are people who
are more interested in one level of
success than another and enabling the
possibility of having that and having
the financial incentives and rewards
that go with it however where i become
more of somebody who's into democratic
socialism is that i believe that the
most successful in our regulated
capitalist system should be paying into
the welfare programs and social goods
that we have to a greater degree than to
have nots so to speak and i believe that
it is perfectly reasonable to say
capitalism it's regulated rules that you
have to abide by in different industries
with peace and love go out there and
build your business but you have certain
rules when it comes to we provide health
care we have certain rules when it comes
to how we damage or deal with the fact
that our business exists on earth and we
have to be aware of how we're impacting
the environment and climate just a few
examples i don't have a problem with
capitalism per se i do have a problem
with unregulated crony capitalism the
way that it's exploded in the u.s. we
have companies paying no tax whatsoever
all of that i have a major problem with
yeah yes so do you think it's regulated
enough that no I don't think currently
we have a enough regulation we see that
in terms of worker safety
we see that in terms of tax
station law for corporations we see that
around I mean even TPP exposes this
desire to create an extra legal right
like this this a tribunal that is higher
than an individual country level where
big corporations would have hearings in
that would circumvent the individual
laws of countries with very op which
very often are not even strong enough so
I don't think we're regulating
capitalism enough the fact that we have
so many people the fact that we have
mass tort lawyers that get settlement
claims for thousands upon thousands of
plaintiffs who have been irreparably
damaged by big corporations all of this
tells us so much about the reality that
we're living in yeah
and can I ask one less thing yeah and
Lewis is he ever coming back no if Lewis
has moved on Louis no longer lives in
Boston I I spoke last week I saw him
over the weekend he's doing fine he's
not doing much but he he's not planning
on living in cities again that I am
aware of and he's planning on moving
somewhere warm so you know the show is
in Boston for the foreseeable future
which gets cold in winter and is a City
so I don't see that working with Louis's
new lifestyle you know okay all right
thank you so much for the call really
appreciate people doing it
thank you we would really really
appreciate the call Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home Tryon to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trialed
dot-com slash TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like $300 for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing